a gunman opened fire at the First
Baptist Church in Sutherland Springs
Texas yesterday 11:30 Eastern time 10:30
local time there in Texas at least 26
killed 20 more injured immediately the
deadliest mass shooting in a place of
worship in the United States
Charleston's Church shooting had nine
deaths 26 so far here and I believe
actually the deadliest mass shooting in
Texas history as well the ages of the
victims ranging from five years old all
the way up to 72 years old the
perpetrator a 26 year old white man
former member of the Air Force is
confirmed by the Air Force by an Air
Force spokeswoman previously
court-martialed for assaulting his
spouse and her kid sentenced to a year
of confinement demoted to the lowest pay
grade of the military and II one and
eventually received a bad conduct
discharge which is just short of a
dishonorable discharge reportedly
connected to this church either directly
or through in-laws also possibly
connected to some others at the church
unless direct ways still to be
determined and reportedly was working as
a security guard also posted pictures of
his firearms to Facebook as recently as
a week ago the way this went is that
this individual 26 year old individual
showed up outside the church entered the
church wearing tactical gear before
entering and after entering did a bunch
of firing of what appears to be a
semi-automatic weapon which would a lot
of these details are still quite early
ultimately he started fleeing the church
and as he was leaving some other guy
with a gun a neighbor of some sort
brought over his rifle and engaged the
gunman and reportedly shot the gunman
once the gunman continued to flee and in
his vehicle this other guy with a gun
flagged down a passing vehicle got in
and a vehicle chase ensued ultimately
the gunman lost control of his car and
died of what as of an hour ago local
authorities are saying was a Sylphide
self-inflicted gunshot wound and that's
relevant to this the gunshot wound that
the shooter sustained
from this so-called Good Samaritan
apparently not the gunshot wound that
actually ultimately killed him police
found the gunman in his car at the
county line dead from a bullet wound
that they believe was a self-inflicted
bullet wound now as soon as this broke
it was abundantly clear the story line
from the right it's gonna be good guy
with a gun killed the bad guy with a gun
good guy with a gun
heroic in defeating the bad guy with the
gun and that is a distraction the real
issue is number one how many people are
trying to solve problems or react to
calamities in their lives with guns how
easy it is to get guns and the reality
that in almost every single one of these
instances guns were not used by
civilians to save the day nor could they
have been think to the dark movie
theater in Aurora Colorado think of the
pulse nightclub dark loud and packed
with people think of the Las Vegas
shooting where the shooter was in a
hotel room 400 yards away dozens of
floors up not to mention that if the
story we currently have is true from
this horrific shooting in Texas the
gunman had likely already killed
everyone that he was going to kill at
the time that he was engaged by this
other dude with a gun
he was already reportedly fleeing he had
already shot up the church outside and
inside and there is danger when you have
untrained civilians participating in
high-speed chases with firearms this is
why 911 dividual when you make a call to
911 say that there is a crime being
committed or you believe that there is
one now of course the reaction from the
right is always different if it's a
white dude who's American or a Muslim
dude Donald Trump took to Twitter after
this happened and said may God be with
the people of Sutherland Springs Texas
the FBI and law enforcement are on the
scene I'm monitoring the situation from
Japan Trump talked about prayer the
focus was prayer during a statement he
made from Tokyo and of course there was
a lot of discussion of prayer because
after all this took place at a church
which raises a lot of questions right I
mean
is the role of Prayer here given that
this took place in a church where a
Christian people were already praying
what what exactly is the relevance of
Prayer well I believe that it is
something that you can say instead of
this was a terrorist attack right when
the shooter is a different color and
religion it was a terrorist attack it's
an animal
we need travel bans and we need more
bombing in the Middle East when it is
yet another one of these white dudes
it's horrible we need prayer and it's
just mental health and for the people
lining up and saying it's not about guns
it's about mental health
what about laws that prevent people with
mental health issues or domestic
violence back backgrounds and having
been confined for acts of domestic
violence
what about laws that prevent them from
getting guns and the legality of the
guns is up in the air there are
conflicting reports that are coming out
and also the the wording of whether or
not this is an act of terror FBI agent
just an hour ago saying they don't
consider this an act of terror right now
Donald Trump calling it an act of evil
not an act of terror and that may well
be the case but we need to consider the
language that is used around these
stories depending on the identity of the
perpetrator
this will sell guns that's the bottom
line these incidents along with
threatening people that the president is
going to take your guns which isn't
happening now but was being threatened
under under President Obama by groups
like the NRA and the right that sells
guns and this will sell guns